earlier this year after much persuasion
and many many many years of putting it
off I finally took the time to bite the
bullet and review Dragon Ball GT from
beginning to end the entire series
episode by episode talking about the bad
the downright terrible the inexplicable
and even some good parts here and there
and a lot of you seem to really like it
but as the final portion of that review
series came to a close I had an idea
Dragon Ball super seems to be seen in a
very similar light to Dragon Ball GT
these days awful embarrassing and lost
are the words that many a fan tends to
call that particular series so I figured
I'd see how it measures up by giving it
the same treatment I gave Dragon Ball GT
now I've had this channel for a number
of years and on it I've spoken about
Dragon Ball super too but I've never
actually taken the time to actually
review the series start to finish and
certainly not the style of detail I went
into with Dragon Ball GT in fact I've
only actually seen this series from
start to finish once all the way through
and between you and me I've actually
skipped a lot of what we'll be talking
about today for the reasons you will see
today you've seen me butcher Dragon Ball
GT s first episodes I'm about to do the
exact same thing here with Dragon Ball
super I'm gonna provide reasons for
every piece of criticism I have and I
will point out all the things I like to
but just fair warning this isn't gonna
be pretty
I've got 131 episodes to get through in
this series so what better place to kick
things off than with the first two arcs
of the show that almost made me quit the
entire series completely which I know
that I think about it would have led me
to never making a YouTube channel and
would have almost certainly led me down
the road of unemployment huh well let's
get this 27 episode at back under way
this is my review for Dragon Ball super
the battle of gods and resurrection f
sagas
having grown up with this series when it
was announced that the Dragon Ball anime
would finally be returning to our
screens with none other than Akira
Toriyama at the helm the excitement
within me was bubbling to the surface
like nothing else I'd get to see Goku a
all the guys again count me in but it
turned out that the first two arcs are
remakes of the movies told through a
series instead of a film like they were
written to be I'm sure this will have
any negative side effects at all so
let's kick things off battle of gods
episode 1 as first episodes go this
really is a mixed bag I distinctly
remember liking it back in the day and
well there are aspects to it that are
nice specifically Goku's interactions
with Goten mr. Satan at the end and
maybe some introductions to beerus the
vast majority of this episode is spent
avoiding the plot entirely it's like
they're trying to spend as much time as
they can reintroducing characters
without any real reason as to why like
there's literally a scene where Vidal
gives Gohan a book and piccolo is seen
staring at them from atop a roof like
play the most important thing piccolo
does in this arc is play bingo but by
far the worst aspect of this particular
episode is the mini story that takes
place within it trunks and goten looking
for a birthday gift for Vidal it doesn't
feel like a part of anything and
distinctly feels like a waste of time
and it's only episode 1 with that said
the ending to this episode I really
enjoyed the compositing and the color
used so it has that going for it episode
2 this episode deals with Vegeta mostly
while the last episode featured a lot of
reintroductions to various characters
that don't add much to the story the
character of focus I thought was Goku
who began and ended that very episode it
served to provide reason and context as
to why Goku was training on King Kai's
planet the place where we find him at
the beginning of battle of gods and so
providing the reason for him to be there
was a nice inclusion that added to the
story or at least enriched it Goku
receives money therefore he gets to go
to King Kai's because chichi allows him
but this episode covers Vegeta mostly
and while admittedly cute it doesn't
provide for the character the same setup
it did for Goku in the episode prior
it's pretty much just him chilling out
with his family on vacation nothing more
before flying off in a huff like you'd
expect him to it does plop him into the
gravity chamber at the end like he was
at the beginning of the battle of gods
movie so at least they're getting into
place albeit in a clunky way episode 3
it's at this point I realized I still
know all the
these lyrics to chose ETSU dynamic the
first theme song to Dragon Ball super
reminding me I've watched way too much
of this show
in this episode bears is on his way back
to his home world with we scrambling
about the Super Saiyan God dream he had
the other night in addition to this the
festivities for boomers party start
getting underway there's not really much
to report here other than it is an
entirely different location to that of
the battle of gods movie the party
taking place on a cruise ship instead of
the briefs compound Goku on the other
hand is still in King Kai's planet but
he's wearing this lovely jogging suit
while they do this really terrible run
animation for way way way too long this
is the first indication of something
serious to follow the animation in this
show is about to tank hard and it only
gets worse from here the best part of
this episode is during the bathhouse
scene with beerus when we sit reduces
him to the man that defeated Frieza much
to beerus is surprised and we see some
nice reanimated scenes of Goku and
Frieza on Namek it's pretty neat episode
4 I hate this episode I hate it I hate
it so so very much I'm not sure if I
hate it because I'm not a fan of the
characters the writing or the fact I
know this entire episode is largely a
massive waste of time but I assume it's
a combination of the aforementioned
beerus is on his way to King Kai's to
confront Goku which is fine but nothing
to write home about King Kai is
stressing out and boomers party is
happening all the while trunks and goten
check out the prizes for the various
games at his mom's party this is when we
catch up with a peel-off game they are
fishing for food the boat is broken and
they see bomas ship passing man what a
coincidence they get chased by a shark
or something eat some food and look for
the Dragon Balls we do get some training
scenes with Vegeta and a much less
visually impressive kamehameha
recreation from the battle of gods film
before beerus and we arrive bringing the
episode to a close episode 5 I can't
begin to describe to you all the joy
that this episode makes me feel but
first a little history the first thing
about this episode is that when it aired
the animation calls the world to point
the finger and laugh at the show I mean
it was awful entirely down to a decision
made by management to give the show a
super short pre-production window and so
after all the worldwide shaming Toey
went back and fixed all of the artwork
to
prove it and they did to their credit
but what they didn't count on was that I
would go out of my way to preserve
history and keep the originally
uncorrected episode that aired in 2015
on my hard drive for years waiting for
this very day to come so enjoy this
uncorrect 'add airdate footage this is
the first action-heavy episode of the
series to which foreign actions Shonen
isn't exactly a good sign
the entire episode deals with Goku's
battle with beers on his search for the
Super Saiyan God which needless to say
doesn't go too well for Goku cycling
through forms that resembles Super
Saiyan 1 2 and eventually 3 which to the
episode's credit has a nice kind of
animation in that form towards the end
my favorite part of this fight however
was this frame I love this drawing
it's like a freeze-frame during one of
those old action movies where you pause
at just the right time to see their
stunt double or something only on this
particular occasion goku stunt double
grins with those vacants unblinking eyes
into york
sure
may he be immortalized forever the
episode ends proper as Vegeta is alerted
to Coco's defeat and beerus is impending
arrival episode 6 this episode is a bit
of fun but again I'm not the biggest fan
Vegeta kicks off the episode while
staring angrily at his hand before
eventually finding he's in the company
of beerus the destroyer who is there
again to look for the Super Saiyan God
Vegeta enjoys a nice little flashback to
his childhood that involves beerus after
falling to the floor this sense of the
president for Machida to have a mental
block with fighting beerus the party
itself continues Vegeta stresses out
makes takoyaki which by the way are
delicious Goten and Trunks have a water
gun fight followed by yet more vegeta
nervous breakdowns the big action
sequence in this episode comes as Vegeta
fights a giant squid and beerus takes
out majin buu over a disagreement
involving pudding main point beerus is
mad despite Vegeta's best efforts so
it's time to fight episode 7 this is
obviously another fighting heavy episode
majin buu vegeta
Gotenks piccolo 1018 and even go on
throw caution to the wind and give it a
go clashing with the god of him beerus
himself is in a hurry to blow up the
planet and leave but we seems too
distracted by the sushi on offer right
as vegeta is in the same position as his
father before him Bulma intervenes and
slaps beerus right in the face hold up I
think it's quite funny here that she of
all people is the first person to land a
blow on beerus however taken aback by
this beerus sends Bulma flying across
the deck with a single slap of his own
causing vegeta to explode with anger
again this isn't nearly as visually
interesting as the film's version but
it's at the very least more interesting
than the rest of the episode and the
majority of this show so far episode 8 I
hate this episode the fight between
bears and Vegeta is average and not
regular average Dragon Ball super
average and the firing of that Gallic
gun always looks awful but that fight
isn't what makes me hate this episode 4
no it's that a large chunk of it is
spent watching the antics that surround
a game of rock-paper-scissors with along
yes I'm serious spoiler alert
beerus wins and begins charging his
blast but goku zere
bring down the top of the ship like a
goof he presents the idea of using
Shenron to help the situation
bringing the Super Saiyan God there for
beerus episode 9 at this point you might
have realized that the story is moving
so goddamn slowly i'm not in a good way
expanding ideas introducing new elements
that adds more tension and depth to the
story no no i'm talking about the
addition of mindless meandering useless
scenes that serve no purpose beyond
bloating a story that was designed for a
film not a series a film in this episode
we are dealing with a portion of the
story that took place an hour into the
film's runtime you know the part where
Gohan learns that his wife is pregnant
which allows him to do the ritual for
the Super Saiyan God yeah
that part meaning it's taken nine weeks
to get to this part of the story and if
you're talking about raw time spent
combined with all nine episodes they've
stretched that first hour of the film to
over three hours in the anime and I feel
every agonizing second of it but who
cares Super Saiyan God is here yay
episode 10 jokes aside this arc isn't
all bad and it does eventually start to
show some of its upsides once the fight
between goku and beerus gets underway on
the aesthetics front it's not impressive
or anything but the artwork and
character likeness has improved greatly
this episode also moves much more than
perhaps any of the other episodes that
came before it with perhaps Episode five
being an exception though the art for
that was well inspirational as you know
what aspect of the fight within battle
of gods I thought lacked in my opinion
was the same thing I thought lacked in
almost any of the Dragonball movie
fights how the story builds up the
spectacle of the battle for me a fight
in Dragonball is difficult to make feel
epic and grand when it's only 15 or 20
minutes long within a film the best
battles in Dragonball have been long and
for me I only get that Dragonball fight
feel when the fight trickles in episode
after episode and in this one Goku
starts to get a handle on the Super
Saiyan God's power and it's a fun watch
in all honesty episode 11 this episode
continues the trend of the last episode
this time improving the animation
introducing more movement and some
wonderful character acting supervised by
Toei animator now quítate the
choreography is also more ambitious than
the last
the action greatly ramping up as Goku
struggles to keep up with the increased
level of intensity beerus has introduced
to the conflict as he elevates the
contest to the stratosphere he also
plays soccer with an energy ball just
like in Dragon Ball fighters though this
episode comes to a close with beerus
stabbing goku the torso sending him
lifelessly falling towards the earth but
in true goku fashion he finds the
strength to soldier on in the face of
certain doom
next episode and this is where the show
pulls the Dragon Ball super and
disappoints me yet again so you know the
way I was complimenting the last few
episodes for their artwork and their
ability to naturally build tension well
this one sort of throws all of that out
the window and replaces it with ninety
percent more screaming doing nothing and
executing the exact same move over and
over and over and over again
this episode makes me bored and angry at
the exact same time which is a weird
combination of emotions I'm riled up but
I'm not interested enough to do anything
about it so anyway goku and beerus
didn't like the last couple of episodes
and so they decide to coast on this one
by screaming and clashing fists again
and again also the animator put Goku's
arm on backwards to block this chop from
beerus I hate this episode episode 13 so
we've made it to the penultimate episode
of the arc thank God as the fight rages
on from a story perspective very little
happens mr. Satan tries to bargain with
Wiest to no success and as goku and
beerus continue to fight goku loses his
guide form however despite this goku
doesn't notice that he continues to push
beerus despite the loss of that form
what is interesting about this episode
is not necessarily the story but that
this is one of the only episodes in the
entire series where tadayoshi of omoro
the character designer of the entire
series decided to command the look of
this particular episode
he pretty much redraws over every single
piece of animation in this one
correcting the character likenesses this
is why every character looks perfectly
on model moreso than perhaps any other
episode in this arc episode 14 in this
episode everything comes to a closed
pretty much the same way it did in the
battle of gods film for the most part
interestingly enough the same animator
that animated this in Dragon Ball super
Brawley real on a sheet animated the
opening sequence on this episode's fight
between goku and beerus flying and
fighting through the water goku puts up
one finals
does well but ultimately cannot deal
with Paris before neutralizing his blast
and impressing the god of destruction
this inspires beerus to spare the earth
well that and he really liked the food
much to the relief of goku and the
others Oh
also before I forget you remember in the
battle of gods movie where Goku suddenly
becomes overcome by a mysterious Super
Saiyan God power to stop beerus as blast
you know demonstrating that he can
control the Super Saiyan God power
without ritual do you know that thing
that shows beerus he's worth keeping
around well forget that in Super Goku
just punches the blast I'm serious he
literally punches the energy blast
that's all it took apparently cool with
overall thoughts on this season are
probably the worst review I could give
anything it's men carts are fine but not
spectacular others are downright boring
and bad bits are dotted throughout it's
the most unremarkable I've seen
Dragonball in a long while safe poorly
executed and boring except for this part
but little did I know what was to come
around the next corner watching this
next arc from start to finish for the
very first time almost broke me it's
time for resurrection episode 15 she she
tells Goku to get to work
Satan commands his adoring public with
tales of how he defeated beerus as a
super saiyan no less an alien show up
that want to challenge him yeah this
actually happens thankfully goku is
nearby when this commotion surfaces and
satan begs him to deal with the alien
invaders goku agrees but before he gets
the chance to fight chichi and piccolo
are nearby and that's what goku delivers
the best joke I've seen produced by
Dragonball KO who basically wants to get
away from chichi here and he knows that
he can't just fly in front of everybody
to get away from her and so he asks mr.
Satan to punch him away this is what
happens
10 outta 10 best episode ever
episode 16 the next episode kicks off
with some very nostalgic very classic
Dragon Ball Z art and animation
unfortunately the animators shuichi
Sakhi only worked on a single episode
during Dragon Ball supers run but it is
cool to see his work here nonetheless
this episode deals with how Vegeta
convinces weeks to take him as his pupil
now one of the aspects I do actually
adore from these first two seasons was
the time and effort taken to link both
arcs of this story together seamlessly
instead of picking up right where the
resurrection F movie does with Goku
Vegeta already in rhesus training it
offers new content that helps set the
scene and I loved every minute of it
also Vegeta struggling to cook as well
as his dynamic with bull ma is always
fun to say episode 17 the last few
episodes and this one included spends a
ton of time focusing on the comedic
aspect of Dragon Ball and honestly I'm
here for it to a degree while I love the
scene where Goku finds out that Vegeta
has been training with weeks for months
and burst through the wall hilariously I
really don't like how childish and
moronic Goku is in the second half of
the episode buggin weeks while he's
eating to training I think this is the
first indication of stupid super Goku in
this series and unfortunately it's gonna
be a trend from here on out
needless to say Goku convinces waste to
train him and so together they make
their way to beers as world for what is
still to this day one of my absolute
favorite episodes in all of Dragon Ball
super episode 18 I love everything about
this episode the animation the character
acting the facial expressions the fun
the lore the story earth it's so fun and
it's so Dragonball I'm a huge fan of
training episodes in anime in general
some of my most fond memories from
Dragonball back in the day was being in
awe at the concept of snake way alone of
seeing King Kai's world that all of that
and so when the time came for Dragon
Ball super to take a swing at this with
Wiese I was so damn ready this is the
episode I watched more times than any
other episode in Dragon Ball super I'm
not kidding I know I'm in the minority
on this one but this was honestly such a
fun watch dealing with the weird and
crazy training techniques of Wiest the
dynamics between goku vegeta
and at times beerus all the while vegeta
dealing with his own insecurities
surrounding the situation if you haven't
seen it check it out it works as a great
standalone episode too and to think this
was made by this
same guy who worked on Episode five it
goes to show time restraints were the
cause and not the talent episode 19 this
episode covers pretty much the beginning
of the resurrection F movie following
the Frieza force reviving their fallen
leader as well as a little bit of
training with Goku and Vegeta but again
nothing nearly as interesting or as new
as the previous episodes in all there's
really not much to write home about here
it's pretty much the same as the movie
only retold in worse quality and what I
like the theme that plays while Frieza
is revived in Dragon Ball super the tune
that blasted my eardrums in the film was
next level hype in comparison episode 20
as I've said in this review time and
again the story rarely deviates much if
at all in any meaningful way from the
original but this time it is different
you see in the movie Frieza kills Takuma
but in this he just blasts him a bunch
he'll be used to stall later don't you
worry something of genuine interest
though is the moment Vegeta and Goku
unlocked Super Saiyan blue is actually
shown on screen though in a nebulous
sort of anticlimactic way sort of
fitting for Super Saiyan blue if you ask
me but I'll address that later there's
some more antics with Jaco a new
character from the Galactic Patrol he
warns everyone that Frieza is on his way
by showing off his drawing skills this
was almost the thumbnail for the video I
kid you not but that's everything in
this episode Oh Krillin gets a haircut
before giving Master Roshi a piggyback
to the action and look it's tension on
episode 21 so the scene is set and all
the Earth's defenders are there Krillin
Roshi tension and go on in piccolo
everything is pretty much the exact same
except remember the way Tagum I didn't
kick the bucket earlier
well his character can now be used to
waste even more time turns out he was
freezes treaty partner during his prep
for Goku and because of that training
tagamet claims to have gotten incredibly
powerful and wild this is explained to
us
Goten and Trunks make their way to the
action episode 22 the episode kicks off
is Takuma rips off Piccolo's arm causing
Gohan to intervene when out of nowhere
Gotenks shows up and hint buts him in
the groin I wish I was kidding
always good to undercut the tension of a
supposedly dire situation with a ball
joke because Gotenks is joke is now over
he conveniently splits up into Goten and
Trunks once again and no we don't see
anything more from them for the rest of
the story I'm glad this scene happened
it was clearly very important and
because the episode is full of things
that literally come out of nowhere
Becki in frolla the captain ginyu was
trapped inside shows up right something
on the floor Takuma reads it and king
who switches bodies with tagamet what in
the name of God is happening as talked
about as ginyu tagamet is powering up we
cut back to Vegeta and Goku as their
training in this special room designed
to help them control their ki like a god
or something we then return to the
action as Gohan is going toe-to-toe with
ki knew until he completely overpowers
him using Super Saiyan Frieza takes this
moment to interject plastron go on with
blast after blast sizing him up for the
final blow when
[Music]
yeah this actually happens again and I
really hate it there's no emotional
weight to it and it feels cheap and
recycled they can play all the sad music
they want I do not understand the
purpose of this scene and I do not care
episode 23 this one pretty much brings a
story back in line with the resurrection
F movie - Piccolo's corpse Goku and
Vegeta get out of that dimension they
were training and go on powers up to max
looking all sorts of scrawny and Goku
finally reaches the battlefield in time
to deflect a blast along with Vegeta who
shows up to show ginyu the door in other
words the episode is saying okay
everybody out it's time for act three we
gotta get back on schedule
next episode 24 these episodes
absolutely so and now episode 27 the
final episode of the okay fine I'll go
back and talk about them episode 24 25
and 26 are absolutely brutal to get
through especially when they first aired
but even if you're talking about the
remasters that corrected a lot of that
downright terrible artwork the animation
is still embarrassingly poor again I'm
not lumping the blame onto the animators
here they are the victims during this
time period the staff behind each
episode would receive copious amounts of
ridicule and scrutiny from online and
the local public completely undeserved
mind you simply because people didn't
understand the time restraints the brass
at Toei put on their schedules some
episodes during this time period had to
be completed in six weeks
less than half of the time a normal
episode should have to be created all of
that aside however the episodes
demonstrate Dragon Ball super at their
most visually uninteresting flat
compositions unimaginative choreography
and ridiculously boring back and forth
between Frieza and Goku these three
episodes demonstrated exactly why
recreating the film's was a boring idea
sitting through this solid hour of bad
super episodes was unbearable to say the
least if you don't believe me check them
out for yourself episode 27 ok we're
finally here episode 27 the final
episode of the arc and it's actually
alright it's not amazing and it's not
really better than the film in many
regards but in one way it actually is I
felt during the film
I was waiting for Vegeta to finally get
his hands on Frieza and what he did it
was amazing and pathetic but it was over
way way too soon in this they actually
allow him to school and style and Frieza
for a little while longer it's nice but
again the majority of the episode is
nothing to write home about outside of
that one instance oh also the music that
plays when Frieza blows up the planet is
terribly suited to the moment it's not
sad it's not even disastrous it's a
track that would be better suited to the
reveal of a Super Saiyan God sort of an
uplifting ethereal track and when
boomers cries of anguish over the loss
of her family ring through that
uplifting number there's the worst sense
of music misplacement it just feels so
wrong and that describes a lot of the
music throughout these first seasons of
Dragon Ball super supplied by Sumitomo
the composer for the series now he is a
great composer I mean he created the
soundtrack for Dragon Ball super Broly
and that has some of my favorite music
to be supply for Dragon Ball in a long
long time
unfortunately for Dragon Ball super the
music met the same fate as the animation
as the pre-production window given to
the series was far far too short to
create a solid artistic vision and a
solid musical soundtrack and that pretty
much concludes Dragon Ball super Sri
hashed retellings of the battle of gods
and resurrection F movies
yikes so usually I spend like two days
or so writing wood of my video scripts
that usually leaves the rest of the week
for drawing thumbnails recording and
handling research for the next video but
not this one this video took me 5 days
to write at least with the first arc of
Dragon Ball G I didn't really know what
was coming with this I knew the story
already and I really didn't want to
watch a version of the same story told
in slow motion I can't on some level
understand the creative teams desire to
remake the film's it is extremely
important for the viewers at home to
understand and know why a purple cat
monster is eating food next to a
flamboyant blue collar store models but
on the other hand the material the added
absolutely did not justify the 14
episodes dedicated to each of these
individual sagas for long expanses of
these arcs so much of it was incredibly
boring and so many of the gags did work
for me with
that said there are some bright spots to
these 27 episodes that I did enjoy as I
said I did like how they linked these
two silos together and episode 18 is
always a treasure gem in this ocean of
mediocrity but overall the first two
arcs I genuinely believe could have been
skipped in favor of the films that do a
much better job save for perhaps the
first few episodes of the resurrection F
saga if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to leave a like it really really
helps also if you want to be one of the
first people to see me collapse into a
puddle of my own tears make sure to
subscribe and turn on that notifications
belt to be one of the first people to
see that video but that will do for this
week thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]